Now that we have shown clique to be NP-complete,
we can easily say that independent set is NP-complete
because we can transform a graph for which you want to solve clique
easily into a graph on which you can solve independent set,
and then that will give you a solution for clique.
So we already have that reduction down here, which of course will make Carol quite unhappy.
And we also had the reduction from independent set to vertex cover
because we showed that solving vertex cover on the graph
is basically the same thing as solving independent set.
So vertex cover is also NP-complete.
So Alice is now unhappy as well.
And what this means is the following:
The problems that Alice, Bob, and Carol are trying to solve
are as hard as any problem in NP can become.
Any problem that you can solve in polynomial time,
if you have had this magic "if-better" function available, would also be solvable
in polynomial time if we found a polynomial-time algorithm for any of their problems.
Or even, in other words, if you found a polynomial-time algorithm for vertex cover,
independent set, clique or SAT, what this would mean is that you have found a way
to simulate the if-better function in polynomial time.
You can simulate a nondeterministic RAM on a deterministic RAM in polynomial time.